I get there it's a mixed prison
it's men and women wow um it's probably
about 70 women there
and about 700 men oh God all all open
plan all integrating the there's a
women's section so
at night time were separated but the
gates were opened I don't know eight
o'clock in the morning or something and
then locked at like eight o'clock at
night so between eight in the morning
and eight at night it's just all free
range it's a self-sufficient Community
within the perimeter of the walls and
you can do anything you want in there
except leave
it's it's literally like there's shops
there's stores there's restaurants
there's
um drugs there's alcohol there's parties